rolling away the roll spent wait where
did moon presents go
what the hell just happened i've never
seen that hey guys i'm jesus here's
toast i'm the blood god of bloodborne
i've had over
6 000 hours i've done speed runs the
world's first no hit run
every kind of challenge run imaginable
but today i'm not going to be playing
we're going to be breaking down a lot of
viral bloodborne videos and just having
a good time
let's check it out oh we're in canehurst
i don't like this i don't like this he
knows what's about to happen
i don't like this i don't like this i
don't like this one like this one like
this
they came for him
so this guy's using the messengers gift
which is an item that allows you to
transform
into messengers pretending that you're a
note but his strategy didn't work these
hunters are too smart for him
whoa i take it back
i take it back he's the smart one baited
him with a
an easy play brought him to another roof
and used the auger of ebrietis to just
push them
off with slimy ratchet noodles
i love it fashion born's the best born
look at this guy with a menses cage not
even a shirt
going into maria you know he's a pro
right there
the spin around dash oh i know what this
is is this guy doing
no roll no sprint
look at this this is gonna be fun
he just see maria is one of those fights
where you can just strafe
around everything the hitboxes in
bloodborne are they 100
accurate no but it's like 99.9
sometimes they'll screw up but if you're
good at the game
and you know how things work you can
just swipe by
like it's nothing and make bosses that
take people
hours and hours and you could do it in
minutes
no hits she's about to transform here he
knows to get away
a big explosion of blood the saw cleaver
is the weapon that he's using
by far the best weapon in the game it
hits like a truck
and it's really fast the big key with
the saw cleaver is you can attack and
then
dodge really quick after it so it
doesn't matter even if you're
aggressive which bloodborne wants to
force you to be
you can just get away if you've made a
mistake
and maria is such a g she just walks
towards you menacing
she's like michael myers it's great he's
waiting for a charge
runs right through it gets the backstab
the double backstab you see he's not
going for viscerals
this might be bl4 because he's doing
such low damage
it's either bl4 new game plus six
something like that
but because you don't level skill you
don't get
any uh buff towards your visceral
attacks so the repost doesn't do very
much damage
that's why he hits her with the double
backstab the backstab causes the counter
hit
and then the next hit hits for twice as
much so you saw 452
to 1401 he probably has extra oh he's
not even using buffs
he's not even using buffs here normally
i like to use the beast blood pellets
for extra damage
that was a good fight that was a great
fight
moon presence coming in hot with the
slams
the dark souls rolling away the roll
spent wait where did moon presence go
what the hell just happened i've never
seen that i think i feel like i've seen
everything in this game i've actually
never seen that before that's insane
moon presence just took a dive
that's crazy we don't know if that's fog
or water some people disagree but either
way she just got dunked on
unbelievable and the fight's not over
he's still got a killer
he's got nothing he's gonna have to mark
back or just quit out here and do it
again
you know what i know nothing about this
game i know absolutely nothing
in cubo's ciso apparently prey
slaughtered nightmare slain
let's go i thought i'd seen everything
we're in mergo's loft this looks like it
might be some pvp action
i feel like i see some hunters yes they
are coming from a long distance
this guy's got the blade of mercy
is he baiting he's baiting not being
there i do this in demon souls all the
time yeah you just
you just play like you're afk and you
just
kill him immediately oldest trick in the
book actually i think i made that trick
back in old school demon souls pvp
he stole my strats i'm kidding
what would i say to people that said
that's a dirty trick and shouldn't be
done
you shouldn't play the game you
shouldn't play the game
this is the pvp in this game the entire
intention
is you're invading someone's world
you're invading someone's world and
you're trying to steal all their stuff
why would you play fair and that is fair
he's standing still
it's it's not like you don't have a
chance to hit him he took his chance but
he missed
ah brush off your shoulders
he thinks he's tough he thinks he's
tough you could tell
you don't you don't use that emo unless
you think you're good
this guy's got a bucket on his head
though i think he's better
the chicago i love the blood effects of
the chicago
it looks so good he's trying to dash
back
oh tried to he thought he was gonna go
in for the punch but he didn't do it
he's retreating there's the mederos
whistle
got baited into a big snake
and the parry into the visceral into the
kill
that's the host and another one
just for the bm on the invader
didn't even need to kill that guy but he
did it just because he could
that's a hunter
now this is bloodborne at its best
the pigs
he just blasted that pig's ass
this is the best did he just go inside
the pig's rectum how do i get that
ability
i need to know how to do this
he's using the pig as bait what a genius
unbelievable i kind of want him to use
the big hammer though
why use a hammer when you could use a
pig
where's the pig trick weapon bloodborne
2 needs a pig trick weapon
we're not even done oh my god
he just uses the pig as cover
when people go to backstab the pig
he slams him with the hammer or he
blasts them with the cannon
that's the most bloodborne thing i've
seen in a while
i mean you're just disgusting in this
game covered in blood and gunk
why not get inside a pig and use it as
cover
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh this is the upcoming playstation one
version of bloodborne
oh man if this game came out when i was
younger i would have been all over this
the sound of the the bell is is pretty
good
it's not the exact sound but it's it's
like the
the lower res version of it the latter
needs work
i'm the latter god he needs better
ladders this is really well done
the animation for the blood vial
i haven't seen too much of this because
usually i'm just you know
mainline bloodborne all day every day
but this is actually really cool
the ladders need work they're pissing me
off
i wonder can you visceral can you parry
oh there's the gunshot
right on cue
yo if this get if this game came out
years ago
i'd be all over it if it comes out
tomorrow i'd play it too
this is bloodborne cart see the
i've been playing bloodborne forever the
rumors
the rumors take on their own identity in
this game
people just make stuff up people were
going
crazy over a reveal of bloodborne cart
every single day people ask me when's
bloodborne cart coming
and i think half of them are serious the
wagon
i would love it if mario kart actually
got a bloodborne cart dlc
i always tell people imagine little
ebrietas steering a go-kart with their
little noodle arms
it'd be the cutest thing nintendo's done
in a while
oh this is i can actually play this it's
it's out already
i think i might try it one day when uh
maybe if i do a speed run and bloodborne
uh kicks my butt
i'll do it to uh release some energy
just a nice little stroll through
yharnam
there needs more monsters like i need
cleric beast howling
and just like jumping in front of your
way obstructing you
this is heaven
i love this i was all about this when
this guy did
this
i need a whole album of this honestly
he's just vibing man he's even got the
look down
that was one of my favorite videos on
twitter ever
the first boss of the game this guy is
too much hair what's wrong with him
jesus christ cut that dude in these
games
starts off with a parry into a visceral
oh this is a speed run
now he hits him with the molly he
doesn't i don't want him to transform
here
get another parry another visceral
another molly
see i'm commentating over myself i don't
even need to be here
hit him immediately we can't let him get
to phase two
he's trying now he's trying
he got to phase two i failed all that's
all that time saying that i i didn't
need to get him to phase two and i
failed
i'm gonna throw molly here wow the molly
just goes
nowhere nowhere how does that happen
welcome to bloodborne welcome to
bloodborne it's just that the game is so
quick and the ai knows what you're
trying to do
i really feel like bloodborne's an
artificial intelligence system
like it it knows when you're backing up
it no it knows
to jump and punch at you
and constantly like the lock on system
doesn't work too
which i should i shouldn't be using it
here but i i try it
who do you think you're talking to
honestly looking back at that i could
have played that so better but that was
just you know
gdq jitters if you speed run all day
every day
you're just gonna it's it's such a
mental grind
the game the game is going to beat you
every which way because you're grinding
rng
so it gets really frustrating but gdq is
the kind of thing where you just want to
have fun
and it doesn't matter if things go bad
and everybody's played bloodborne
everybody knows how bad it can get so
the fact that it did get that bad
it just made it more fun all right now
this is the moment you guys have been
waiting for this is what i was talking
about before
this is the best area in the game why
ladders
look at this ladder it's a wooden ladder
this is just pure nonsense
so basically i look at gdq
my first gdq as my super bowl it was the
biggest
thing that i have ever done as a
streamer
and there's so many people watching you
you have such an opportunity to show off
what you can do
and i was a bloodborne speedrunner and
bloodborne speedruns
are super fun there's bosses around
every corner
enemies that can kill you every which
way but there's this one part in the
game where you have to run through the
entirety of the forbidden woods
go through the back end of the clinic
and just basically get a few items
it's it takes five six minutes so
i didn't think that that would be a
great thing to just say
okay now is a perfect time for donations
which is what a lot of people do at gdq
if there's a boring section of the run
so i kind of turned the run's weakest
point
into its strongest point and that's
where i created the latter meme and the
latter joke and
having the ability to get a crowd
chanting for ladders i still think that
might be the funniest thing that i've
ever done on the platform
i've got the best the best ladders but
now now guys now it's really over
there's no more ladders
the wooden ladders the twins it's done
we have no more fun
the rest of this this run is gonna be
completely completely serious no more
shenanigans
nothing nothing we're not even gonna
mention the metal ladder that's coming
up
right now three ladders in a row
all right now the rest of this place
boring thank you guys so much for
watching i had a lot of fun doing this
i'm jesus here's toast you can find me
over at twitch.tv
slash jesus here's toast you can also
find me on youtube or
twitter at jesus toast i love to play
bloodborne i love to play
souls games and souls likes and i just
like to have fun
and i also like to get angry when i
don't have fun
thanks for watching
[Music]
you